der 32 spieltag hat es in sich es gibt
einige überraschungen und hier jetzt an
die 34 tore in knapp neun minuten
wir starten mit den beiden
montagsspielen der europa league
halbfinalisten eintracht frankfurt
rotiert kräftig in leverkusen vor dem
rückspiel gegen west ham die werks-elf
geht nach 18 minuten in führung stärker
pass von diaby mit dem außenrist
paulinho tunnelt trapp das ist pech für
den tod
in der 51 minute das 2 0 auch der ball
geht dem frankfurter keeper durch die
beine patrick saisontor nummer 22 dabei
bleibt's in leverkusen bayer festigte
rang drei im kampf um die champions
league
borussia mönchengladbach empfängt
leipzig das genau wie frankfurt noch
international unterwegs war und jetzt
ebenfalls contest tc rw dass der ball
genau wm ball landet das eins zu null
die gäste müde aber sie kämpfen und auf
einen ist in dieser saison immer verlass
christopher im kongo seien 34 das porta
punkt in der liga eine fantastische
quote
in der nachspielzeit der ersten hälfte
das 2 1 für die fohlen jonas hofmann
doch dann wird's noch mal eng rote karte
für elvedi und das ist der grund
notbremse gegen kongo klares foul
ein treffer fällt danach noch trotz
unterzahl allerdings für die borussia
wieder ist es hofmann das 3 zu 1 der
endstand gladbach gewinnt das spiel aber
verliert am saisonende mathias ginter
der wohl nach freiburg wechselt
genau dort könnte er allerdings
vielleicht champions league spielen denn
der sportclub überholt er bleibt sich
durch den sieg bei der tsg hoffenheim
die gäste starten besser ins spiel das 0
1 durch schollen doch die tsg kommt
zurück toller ball von raum auf
grammatik das 1 1 der pausenstand
danach geht es schlag auf schlag erst
stille mit einem platzierten schuss zum
2 2
nur eine minute später ist günther auf
der anderen seite zur stelle der kapitän
des sport clubs zieht ebenfalls ab und
trifft zum ausgleich die breisgauer
jetzt besser im spiel als die
kraichgauer erst das 2 2 durch müller
dann erhöhte nach vorarbeit von
schlotterbeck der nach dortmund wechseln
wird
in der 84 minute markiert rudi den
anschlusstreffer der wahl ist vor dem
nachschuss von ritter schon drin doch
zur aufholjagd kommt es nicht mehr der
sc freiburg gewinnt ein turbulentes
spiel mit 4 zu 3
[Applaus]
mainz 05 gegen den frischgebackenen
meister den fc bayern in schwarz und dhl
fliegt gleich richtig los erst burkhardt
mit dem 1 0
und dann erhöht niag at nach nicht mal
einer halben stunde die zwei tore
führung durchaus überraschend bei den
münchnern fehlt es ein wenig an
körperspannung und konzentration zwar
markiert lewandowski mit seinem 34
saisontor den anschlusstreffer aber
mainz schlägt noch mal zurück 57 minute
barreiro mit etwas glück dass drei zu
eins gleichzeitig der endstand ein
wichtiger sieg für die nullfünfer die
bayern machen schnell den abflug einen
großteil des teams verabschiedet sich
nach dem spiel in richtung die pizza
eine verrückte partie sehen mehr als
80.000 fans in dortmund zwischen dem bvb
und dem vfl bochum der nach nur drei
minuten durch folter bereits in führung
die
super start der gäste und er wird noch
besser 18 minute holtmann 0 zu 2 dort
nun zunächst von der rolle aber dann
bühne frei für erling holland
wege erzielt einen dreier pack macht
erst das 1 2 und dann den ausgleich
jeweils per handelfmeter 2 zu 2 halbe
stunde gespielt
zur führung tritt holland in hälfte zwei
aus dem spiel heraus er dreht die partie
fast im alleingang aber halt nur nicht
zu früh freuen bochum kommt nochmal
lokal mit starker technik 33 ab in die
schlussphase der dritte handelfmeter in
diesem spiel auch pantelic verwandelt
der vfl bochum gewinnt mit 4 zu 3 in
dortmund sichert sich den klassenerhalt
und dann gibt's kein halten mehr
[Applaus]
auswärtspartie machen und vier tore
schießen kein problem das können wir
denken sich die kölner in augsburg und
der plan geht auf thielmann mit dem
frühen 0 zu 1 der fca kommt überhaupt
nicht ins spiel
gut erhöht schon nach einer knappen
viertelstunde auf 0 2 und aus sicht des
heimteams wird es noch schlimmer
nach diesem foul an modells trägt der
sich selbst in die torschützenliste ein
augsburg kommt durch niederlechner zwar
ein klein wenig näher 73 minute doch die
freude hielt nicht lange zehn minuten
später trifft wieder modell ist sein 20
saisontor zum 14 das auch der endstand
der fc auf kurs richtung europa league
von der träumt auch union berlin noch
greuther fürth hingegen ist bereits
abgestiegen eigentlich klare
voraussetzungen doch das kleeblatt geht
überraschenden führung und die branimir
evita nach einer guten halben stunde zum
[Musik]
in hälfte zwei helfen die gäste
ordentlich mit so kommen die berliner
durch sven michel zwar zum ausgleich
aber mehr ist nicht drin es bleibt beim
1 1 zu 1 aus unions sicht sind das zwei
punkte zu wenig
ab in den abstiegskampf stuttgart
empfängt wolfsburg und braucht dringend
einen sieg doch zunächst gehen die gäste
in führung brooks mit dem 0 2 1
[Applaus]
der vfb gibt alles aber es dauert bis
zur 89 minute dann trifft für ich zum
ausgleich aufbruchstimmung bei den
stuttgartern mit riesiger unterstützung
der fans aber es reicht nicht zum sieg
entstand eins zu eins der vfb muss um
den klassenerhalt bangen
große chance also für hertha bsc oder
arminia bielefeld durch das stuttgarter
remy mit einem sieg wären die berliner
gerettet und zunächst läuft auch alles
nach plan für das team von felix magath
das 0 1 durch zu sein
der jubel groß und um ein haar wäre der
vorzeitige klassenerhalt in der 88
minute perfekt geworden aber
wollschläger & mittelstädt spielen nimm
du ich habe ihn sicher das recht sich
sofort jetzt geht es in die andere
richtung nachspielzeit nilsson mit dem
ausgleich eins zu eins ekstase auf der
alb
durch das unentschieden zwischen der
arminia und der hertha bleibt erstens
alles beim alten und zweitens der
abstiegskampf extrem spannend
die gesammelten ergebnisse viele tore an
diesem 32 spieltag bis auf frankfurt
erzielt jede mannschaft mindestens einen
treffer bochum und freiburg gewinnen
will die partien jeweils mit 4 zu 3 in
der tabelle ist freiburg der große
gewinner der sc überholt leipzig und
steht jetzt auf einem
champions-league-platz köln und union
tauschen die ränge damit wären die
geißböcke für die europa league
qualifiziert
bochum feiert den klassenerhalt von
platz 14 bis 18 tut sich gar nichts das
heißt es bleibt eng bis auf führt steht
noch kein absteiger fest
[Musik]